hey guys welcome to another episode of
impaired I am JC cariah's and I am Chris
cope and we're the yin and yang of
getting [ __ ] up I am a notorious
alcoholic and I am the world's best
owner what we like to do on this show is
bring our buddies on and then we get
them all [ __ ] up we drink and we smoke
and we play a bunch of fun games and
then see what happens there it is let's
bring out our guests all right
in zero function about the haters and
only cares about the
named after if dude
[Music]
don't play go from Jupiter Florida
hey guys welcome to impaired give it up
for our guests coming in air so George
says meet Caleb sided everybody hey it's
one of those things where we like to
start a start an episode with a nice
shot cheers Cheers it tastes like the
islands that was that that was um
there's a look there was a Jameson and
then a little bit of little bit of a
little bit of orange juice and a little
bit of grenadine gang that was very
yummy yeah you call that one I call that
one the welcome to the show sure yeah I
made the same one for the last episode
which was nice also we shot it
back-to-back so me and Chris have
already begun this party so it's oh yeah
are you guys yeah um during the show
guys oh yeah holding the whole show
there's a secret word that the producers
have come up with and once someone says
it you will hear the phrase I'm and you
can stop what you know the words been
said we'll figure out exactly what it is
and we'll take a big ol drink yeah
alabaster is my birthstone even know I
didn't know I'd never heard of a
birthstone and I was still impressed
what's your what's your birth month July
July okay so look it up best way to
explain it
what's your birth month yeah good
I have no idea Brown love it love it
love it
all right I'll go ahead and do it after
cool all my favorite segments hometown
harassment basically I looked up a bunch
of facts about these gentlemen's
hometowns and their knots not them I'm
just trying to wait their turn and not
the best light okay so I'm gonna start
with Aristotle he's from Jupiter fool I
want to jump it Chris is the word the
introduction we literally have to do
this we go what are the fixed words we
have to say see Sam he can't improv it
or change it it's garbage
look it already comes out like gotta
clattering nobody's watching this show
hoping for snappy in [ __ ] up I know
what they did they get it I know where
they're at
I love the show but needs more clean in
track I need structure all right okay so
Jupiter mm-hmm I will bring the fact
that you're sadist
your biggest scandal is about a guy who
would not take his American flag down he
put a flagpole on American flag I'm
[ __ ] yard and the neighbor's
Association was like you got to take it
down he's like no [ __ ] you he took away
the court the government the governor
showed up wow that just goes to show you
like what a lovely [ __ ] place jupiter
florida is now you say that it's like
that sleepy beach town but how this real
cooz you guys like that [ __ ]
dude obviously none no sirree
I mean maybe tell some Florida scared
the [ __ ] outta me
that means they're rnase I'm got caught
exactly so they're good at coming here
Law & Order has been lying to us guys
they have a serial killer every other
episode there's only been 350 in the
entire time the United States has been
around what do you like the lawyer for
serial a seeker is professional lawyer
why you know that I tried to write a bit
about it [ __ ] terrible we don't end
any other serial killers watching we
should they need a Casper mattress I
will jump it and say that the cat box is
so small how do they how do they do God
you ask Chris yeah they always try to
tell you more stuff about it this
[Music]
extremely disheartening in the 1920s and
30s the the police force I actually got
a perfect a portion of the tickets that
they wrote so for every ticket they
wrote they got a slice of that fine oh
yeah see there's a huge [ __ ]
article about everything I looked it up
yeah well that is what makes them want
to do their job better
it keeps the town safe most serial
killers that don't exist you were a very
untrue
thank you yeah I mean I'm telling you is
a wonderful upbringing I had you never
got a speeding ticket Jupiter I did
huh-uh
- but one like I definitely deserved and
then and then one I was like I was like
aw come on man I'm gonna work you know
but like how well the one that I
deserved I was like street racing so I
was like going like 80 and a 45 apology
right yeah more than a speeding ticket
problems no that's all that was like so
nice I was like you got me
you were very polite yes I seem fast and
furious too many times I was like I'm
just I'm just letting out my hormones
chill and then the one you didn't
deserve and then when I didn't deserve I
was going like 55 and a 45 I was late
for work [ __ ] you got me and I was like
I'm in my uniform you just let me go I
got can't let you go one of those guys I
feel like there's a lot of those guys I
had when they pulled me over they go or
you're on your way to the hospital
and I always say no and I'm like I'd
shake said yeah yeah yeah I'm never home
everybody knew I've never had a police
officer say that to me we've been pulled
over Saturday that's priori like we
don't look as sick as in the past no I
look sicker than you came I feel like
every time I'm in a car
someone should assume I'm driving he
sees going to his nephew's Bar Mitzvah
for the party place the fun time if you
have more facts first
give me more facts well there is
something about that hometown Jupiter
for that I love the most and it's it
goes back to my white-trash roots and my
Burt Reynolds is from me oh yeah it
actually spotted him really you better
yes I mean doing NEFT I mean he just
being Burt yeah man that could be in
fire yeah it was funny because I wanted
to show him the town more but I'm like -
Scott Burt Reynolds and I love his
terrible ass movies he's made some dog
[ __ ] he's made some of the best movies
ever though smoking the Bandit I always
point this out Christos all of our
research you see he's nude photos okay
Oh on the bear rug instead of seventies
yeah I mean the guy [ __ ] was four for
five years in a row the guy was a top
drawing box office oh yeah Oh
or the nikuman is 60 or he was 38 38
draw I Faden I think that's a little bit
of Christmas top 100 our researcher
wonder why you would drop them that much
I think he got less handsome
he start making eggs have daunt like
never cop and a half no money they made
and everything I made but thing is he
made like smoking the bandit and
cannibal I was funny about Burt Reynolds
his biggest so the stupidest thing he's
ever done was to turn down terms of
endearment to do Cannonball Run
oh oh you realize how much money he was
probably getting to do cannonball shows
up Burt Reynolds but I mean once you're
that rich what does it matter if you get
more like well what does Berger it's
probably not starting carry cash yeah
Burt life dude yeah all he's doing is
spending money oh now I'm on your side I
turned your okay change my mind so easy
you go jumping let's jump in a caleb
right now oh no oh [ __ ] yes
now here you got it it's real easy throw
into the camera right now you're the
tourism director of Jupiter Florida
mm-hmm
give that pitch bring them into Jupiter
okay come on here it is steal my
punchline come on down to Jupiter we
don't have any serial killers
[Applause]
glasses all right yeah alabaster that
more guests are wearing glasses oh [ __ ]
alabaster what's a homonym I don't wanna
do the joke hominem I'm a word that
sounds the same as another word but
isn't like sentence sent yes sentence
sense male and male yep you're good man
I can't think of any sale a sale those
are my least favorite hip hop rhymes
would be like when they hominy Minelli
go come on it's not sales my albums like
to sail yeah I'm like no no no lil wayne
is famous for homina homina moving yeah
for hominem and eminent guys like a
hobbit blows away
no but see I feel like you think Fat Joe
Fat Joe but he was smaller than Big Pun
and should have been fat pun and it
should have been Big Joe this is like a
Jerry Seinfeld
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'll kill myself
we should have another one if anyone
uses the Lord's name in vain that one
was good too I'm a pretty good bartender
yeah what the hell I know if you didn't
know already I'm a drunk okay let's jump
in a cab here from Royston Georgia
that's right oh [ __ ] Jordana be now
there's nothing I like about Royston
Georgia Chris looked it up he does all
of our research I think I've mentioned
that it is the home to a museum for Ty
Cobb the most racist baseball player he
was considered a saintly lazy and that's
outrageous he was when there were black
players he would spike them he would
slidin spiked up oh yeah Wow here's the
worst part we also named the hospital
after so he was known to like hurt all
the time after him
I told the joke about him on cone and
they wrote me up in the paper and we're
like mad they don't like that I'm still
not I still have not surpassed Oh
still has like the batting average
record so it's like you know no one's
ever gonna out hit him yeah and what
what could I do correctly that would be
that good it's just comedic ly that out
racism I mean don't worry about being
the most you could have went on the
Conan and just said the n-word for five
minutes I could better than I cop on his
best day oh like dude there was a
gentleman called him a name from the
stands yeah yeah I'll give you a hint
comes into the stands puts the guy in
the hospital fun fact the guy had no
hands he beat a dude that had no hands
for basically calling him half of
something and you know where they took
him Ty Cobb memorial investors in
coca-cola we made a lot of money I think
how do you think his kids feel about it
so this is another cow baby this is uh
this is Chris cope at his best with his
research on the city of Royston 's
website under collection under the
section things to do it says go to
Atlanta leave this [ __ ] all rise that's
amazing
how far away is close I left this should
be I can't believe I don't have this bit
we just rip no no that's that's weird go
to a heaven I like doing the cards
Thanks that is so funny that is
remarkable since 2000 poison has lost
three percent of its population Caleb go
ahead give that camera you're the you're
the guy bringing him back bring it back
bring them back but welcome to Royston
one of the few places that doesn't
suffer from overpopulation because 3% of
our baby was murdered by serial killers
from jupiter floor now there's not there
it's all come on down to Royston noise
oh my god I love it it's great
bryceton Roy hey gang that was hometown
harassment baby yeah man
rock'n'roll let us off man the next one
we're gonna do is I it's a fun game
called teachers let it let it out but
let everybody know and Ally so we will
all we've all came up with tutors and
we're gonna figure out which one it is
we'll start we'll go Jesse we'll start a
Jesse got it I know how to juggle wait
let me see that's not fair wow it's so
fast it's over like a demon I think
we're gonna pass right over to Chris no
[ __ ] man I thought it was good
I'm sorry I'm pretty low hilarious okay
I was born in Tallahassee Florida I have
won $10,000 on the game show
and I have the vault and a high-speed
chase I don't think you're born in
Tallahassee okay I was gonna do the same
thing because I think you're probably
further a little further so what's out
happy as well all right what is soul
mate you're moaning because Chris not
only used one of the things from the
last episode
then he stole somebody else's story it
works it works we don't know that they
might I can't they know they know but I
can tell them how what I'm saying is I
can't guess because it'll give like a
funnel Easter Egg for the viewers yeah
it up their little way did he just feel
Jackson's story yeah if they're watching
two episodes in a row they're still like
I don't like to eat I like to call him
out that's pretty much where the votes
were she living together I'm just
constantly giving him [ __ ] all right so
reveal I was never a car chase $1,000 in
a marathon
celebrity name game I was born in
Tallahassee no more a hospital uh on
March 5th in Tallahassee I grew up in
acres and yeah never was in a high-speed
car chase
what'd you do that $10,000 yeah oh this
is about to be another lie it's just
less interesting all up my nose
[Applause]
one round huh all right that was to go I
know I was gonna end the I wasn't in the
segment without letting our guests
arguably the most important sake fellas
yeah the only reason to play the goddamn
game was it go first claim it all right
Caleb I've never done cocaine mm-hmm
I dropped out of college I am 23 okay
okay okay fine out here's what I got
if you're 23 kinds of things because of
the hold on because of the Lord's name
in vain I'm gonna choose cocaine and
most of the time I choose cocaine as
well so i'm gonna choose cocaine that's
my that's my guess what my lies your lie
that's your line that's my that's my
guess out of context that just sounded
like you just chose cocaine that's the
platform so if the lie would be the
light would be that I had okay vote for
me is a vote for coke never done that
was what I said
yeah oh [ __ ] I'm not listening now I
feel just cocaine right cuz that's the
platform 2028 what a flat floor nachos
okay the unsustainable I just your voice
is older than 23 my friend okay I don't
know [ __ ] you know a guy swing on you
Chris is gonna be very upset I'm not 23
I'm 26
Wow Spears alright those are two eyes
two eyes it's two transom no I have
never done it I did drop her I misheard
him just I I didn't know that would be
the most difficult game was surprising
[Laughter]
glasses oh sure you can tell me I don't
look like there we go finally the end
like I'm gonna bomb everybody it really
does change everything yeah really
changes your face damn dude
doctor I can't see out of them no what
else would it be like I'm getting lazy
with the charities I'm drinking it and
leaning over all right but good segment
segment ain't over baby oh boy
okay cheese reason why yeah I know how
to juggle
[Laughter]
[Music]
djing EDC this year silly like
background laughter love it
I can't wait to the studio audience gets
in and I've had a threesome he wasn't
here I wasn't how could he steal from
the episode pass and we didn't hear it
no and still other people judge juggling
exists okay Chris hard he did it
no but [ __ ] guess he's just not he's
just at his house I just think it's like
he's just sitting in his goddamn house
he's done my guess is you can't juggle
you don't think he can jump I think
you're gonna DJ some kind of weird a
stupid thing where you gonna do a bunch
of look what you're wearing a camera
what you're doing ice beer you with a
jacket yeah that's true you can't travel
for [ __ ] I don't know how's it supposed
to taste
I've never be real good I've never had
any goddamn yes I've never had ice beer
do you think there's any Tecate snobs
that are like Oh
[Laughter]
Carol I think you're holy so you don't
that you think he can't juggle I don't
think you can juggle either if you can
juggle you can have a threesome so that
doesn't make sense
okay life okay so I'm gonna vote
I could really can't say juggling
because it was my life and I don't think
that he has the balls to double why I'm
here lie that would be impressive if
that's the case I like how you guys all
jumped on to the juggling thing like he
took my lion rolls everything is mine
juggle I want to see it my vote is
threesome okay
are you serious like he's a handsome man
if you had a free yeah I did you did I
haven't had a threesome with the Gary
the last episode yeah it was Lachlan
Patterson and physical Sonny
hey no did you juggle those I'll do it
sitting down I'm gonna get out your
weight of a [ __ ]
here you go the best is Chris's reaction
to I'll be a son of a [ __ ]
all right now [ __ ] two people
oh my god I'm having such a wonderful
time this is really fun
that's great I swear when we get when I
reach out to people to do this because
you know how we're gonna go to a studio
in Burbank and have a fine ass time
right just go and I start and I serve
beers mmm next thing opposed eyes are
wasting oh my god hey I'll handle so
what we do every week is we like to make
a Munchie dish so it's like a misma a
mix mash of all the things that could be
in your kitchen and you're high or
you're drunk and you just need something
to eat
gah so you got the munchies and here
comes a wasting for you
[Music]
we're back everybody
I hope you enjoyed the creation of the
fat deborah everybody look at that
weight that majestic beautiful thing
right there
who is Debra who is Debra it's lose that
baby's products
it's an oatmeal cream pie in the middle
okay a cosmic brown heat a little kind
of hold on scream on top um so it's time
to center
I love how these her formal name for the
most weight that Nutella yeah there's no
tell in it look who your hosts are bud
take a gander at who's deciding what the
thing we're making and know that yeah
that's what's happening guys it's like
not bad know about not bad there's
nothing bad in it ever I like how how
could it be I just want how could that
be bad it can't be how could it be bad
it can't be it seems like something I
didn't eat it's actually in front of
people ever oh the Little Debbie cake
kind of it's not too sweet I'm ruining
my fingers coming up next table it's the
greatest fans I'm sure he had a little
problem but the man can hit a ball I
love him people something so people will
always know like oh he was flawed and
I'm like flaws meeting a man does he
call you a name yeah
flawed is like you know little dinner oh
god here we many what sort of host would
I be without handing out some of these
to our
I wasn't I'm not having dinner with my
wife tonight after this dude you're
gonna run home after this [ __ ] sugar
you made it seem like you were gonna die
I'm not having dinner with my wife after
this no I think because we have dinner
we were gonna have dinner together and
then I'm like not why didn't mean to
take that away from me family I'm glad
you did oh my god that is the definition
of decadence what was the last snack
before the fat member was like last oh
the last time it was a big goodbye so
like instead of a baby bagel bite we'd
made a full bangle with the sauce cheese
all right and then to set it off you
know because that's what we like to do
here at the show we stabbed with the
bangle several times with a cheese whiz
and neat humped the bagel filled with
cheese with it's like a Boston cream pie
and with a bagel and cheddar cheese
Lestrade she's had is [ __ ] awesome
yeah delicious isn't way better than I
thought was gonna be I mean it's pretty
hard to be happier Yeah right I didn't
know it did [ __ ] remarkable yeah I
think Caleb you're the first person
no actually as I said I you're the first
person to eat your full thing but no
last time Lachlan ate his entire pizza
bagel I almost all of it - yeah pizza
bagel is good we've had we did one where
we did like a pizza burrito and
everybody kind of let's - we're trying
to enjoy it but it's just had so much Oh
dabbing off with the with your ice beer
yeah alcohol cleans things mmm Tecate
best on ice like a glass of white wine
that would be really a really funny it
was like I just brought about
I'm drinking already doing karate
you got carjacked by three guys fought
one man right she fought one man he'd
beat him physically to death
pistol-whipped him he's going to get his
gun jammed him they ran off he gone
wrong train played a double-header I hit
four four nine so he killed somebody an
investigator got bit was like it's
self-defense they try to carjack me I
got I got I got stabbed by the other guy
they ran off Chris can I say something
why with your accent you shouldn't know
anytime cop the man was dignified he was
a monster it was a month but honestly
they daddy's my girfriend just go if you
believe you couldn't have baseball they
would have hung you before you were 15
impaired we do not approve of Ty Cobb
thank you told that carjacking story it
sounded like you were his ears more
money how would you say
I'll tell you a story about a cop a
little brush-up about a cop with wonder
be the man to death with a pistol went 4
for 9 maybe about me spending 400 a
Christmas you can't deny the badassness
of that though [ __ ] do you what a legend
he carried a pistol like he was like he
just didn't give a [ __ ] that that's all
it takes for Christmas call somebody a
legend he carried a pistol no I never
said that
alright when we got next but here in a
badge
it's bigger a bar today oh my god this
is my favorite segment so the way it
works is we're gonna try and make this
cocktail and then I'm going to change
the other cocktails I'm gonna choose a
winner the best-tasting one and then
there'll be a secondary winner of who
gets it right now the fun part of it is
if you want to [ __ ] with me
you know that you could make a terrible
cocktail I'm still going to drink from
that guy be your own bartender boys
let's hear that all right today cocktail
of the Tom Collins the recipe dates back
to 1876
it's a prohibition-era drink those
invented as a way to hide the scent and
flavor of poor quality homemade spirit
okay okay we heard a minute 1/2 which
begins now choose your booze and go hey
I'm gonna go with Bushmills whiskey
sounds right remember minute-and-a-half
gang talk it out a little bit
I'm feeling what I'm feeling it wasn't
getting their own [ __ ] going on I don't
want to give away my secret don't give
away your secret I also don't know what
I'm doing like that that's my favorite
thing about the game oh yeah yeah Chris
always likes to garnish hmm
Chris just got dethroned this is the
first episode - Chris lost he made the
best drink every time and made the
closest every time oh my god just all
over myself I've already done it how
much time we got 30 seconds we're
already on the shaker face oh oh that's
cold
it's all right it's all right guys we'll
get him into the cups actually gonna
pull app okay
I feel like the cocktail I make always
looks the same goddamn color 10 seconds
boy boy there's no way I'm right I just
I was just a fun boy they'd like time
dead time now let's uh let's let's let
the cameras take a gander at him hold
him up hold him up before it hears now a
little red everybody take a gander at
what's going on very red I feel like
everybody went with at least grenadine
or cranberry Chris good describe your
beverage okay mine is I use vodka used
by whose grenadine could it eat lived a
simple syrup like a fine apple and then
I took I squeezed the fresh orange in
there and then I put it in there when I
shook it up fantastic see on Kate
it doesn't smell bad
the last beverage you made was terrible
was it real bad yeah that's pretty
goddamn good really it's pretty goddamn
good Wow guys it's pretty good shots
okay it's refreshing it's got a real
sweet no bad like it a lot no bad I
think I like that one a large in there I
think
really oranges Oh oh it's good I don't
look I'm close to what a [ __ ] song I
don't think you are I don't think any of
us got anywhere near close maybe you did
I might have that looks like a great
that looks like a drink of the way he
held it up but here's a confidence - hi
- hey what do we got for well I forgot
what I put in here oh well that's that's
gonna be a bad start Danny describing
bed it was looking at me he's gambling
on it I think I put gin yes he went Jen
Jen and club soda gin club soda and like
I squeezed either a lemon or a lime
let's look in here ensue and I over I
just kind of poured the grenadine
obviously not red I can see the pieces
of lime will hold that out so really
squeezed it in its gonna have some
chunks you always want that chunky Tom
Collins chunky Thomas chunky down yeah I
[ __ ] love that god I [ __ ] love it
because it's not because Christmas is
overly sweet that is gin and I don't
like gin but it covers it all the way
wow that's a great [ __ ] drink
I wish you'd remember how you made it
that's good it's a good [ __ ] drink
yummy and I know gin it wasn't too sweet
that's the thing I like I put a little
of this whatever this final pineapple in
there and lime that's good Thomas thanks
though chunky Tom junkie Thomas we made
a new drink I start of describe what's
going on here okay so I went to filled
to the brim I'm about I'm about I used
to be a bartender in college but I don't
remember that can bartender we've had on
the show but I don't remember like a lot
of it so but I'm pretty sure Tom Collins
has gin so I started with a base of gin
basically and then I did a little
bit of coca-cola oh yeah I don't think
that's right but [ __ ] true and then I
did most of the cherry juice dumped
cherry juice in there yes you can sir
let him describe was drink it I put the
orange in there and I left the rind and
throw a cherry in there in the bottom so
if you reach down there I see it also
there's it seems like there's some fizz
in it did you use anything I did put a
little splash of club splasher club and
it seems well Christmas a problem at all
times and if there was a way I can host
it without him I would I'm gonna try it
it looks like it really does look like a
beverage that made by a bartender at a
at a at a bar yeah all right very
charity
really really good well a lot of
charities but I think it's better than
easy Tom Collins quite nice it's really
really refreshing yeah a little watered
really refreshing yeah no mines garbage
it's [ __ ] vodka no no it's Bushmills
it's Bushmills cranberry orange juice is
gonna taste like dog [ __ ] no it's gonna
be delicious
mmm-hmm that's pretty much what I made
before it's okay
if I had to rate them taste wise well I
gotta get I wanted it looks like there's
a disease in here it looks like I made a
disease in a cup I did good at the top
man I got a boat all the way for
Aristotle's drink Oh fantastic
Caleb drink oh one second what's what's
the actual breakdown of the I just added
coke good honestly I would drink the
rest of this and I might hey guys thank
you so much for being on the show check
us out hey guys please keep watching us
we need to keep drinking and smoking
working late
where can we see you guys where can we
catch you guys up oh you can catch me
everywhere [ __ ] yeah you catch me Ty
Cobb Museum I host the tour there's an
open line at Twitter at städel and then
also an instagram at bottomless bottle
and Blake Weber
hey well my last name sucks to say so if
you're just google caleb conan off my
youtube clip from Conan will come up and
follow me from there cuz no one knows I
say my last name and this guy's gonna be
on Conan like yeah crash wagon with
bhaijaan everything is Chris Koch comedy
Twitter's microscope comedy Instagram
website Chris Koch comedy Wow you can
find anything on Twitter at JC stand-up
and on Instagram and Jason comedian
thank you guys so much for sticking
around and watching us get drunk and we
stupid hey Cheers Luzi another episode
[Music]